There are women are very good in high
school.
Then they go to college.
They're very good.
In College,
they had nailed her damn grades.
They do their studying,
they get their a's and they end the ace
Al Sat,
so they're smart too.
Then they go off to do their articling
and they're really,
really good at it and then they get
offered an associate position and
they're really,
really good at it and then by the time
they're 30,
they make partner and let's say they're
in high pressure,
high paying jobs,
$250,000
a year.
$300,000
$500 an hour.
Okay.
What's your life like?
You work all the time,
period.
Seventy hours a week,
75 hours a week,
flat out,
and you don't get to make any mistakes
and if your client calls you at three in
the morning on Monday,
on Sunday you say,
I'm really glad to hear you hear from
you because if you don't,
there's some hot law firm in New York
that'll take your client from you at a
moment's notice and the client is paying
you whatever the firm,
$750 an hour of which maybe you get 3:50
and what they want is an answer about
something really complicated right?
Bloody now,
and you can say all you want about the
fact that women have a difficult time
with that because it's a male dominant
patriarchy.
Any any female lawyer who's hit 30 and
his partner that has any sense at all
knows that complete bloody rubbish.
It's market determined right to the
core.
What happens to the women when they're
in their thirties?
They all leave the high end law firms.
Why?
Because who in their right mind would
want to live like that?
That's the issue,
right?
Once you make about $60,000
a year for your family,
but let's say for you personally,
additional income makes zero has zero
impact on your quality of life,
zero,
so why work 80 hours a week while men
will do it?
Some men,
very few,
a handful of hyper competitive men who
are obsessed with hitting the pinnacle
of the given dominance hierarchy there
in will happily work 80 hours a week and
they'll forgo everything else.
Relationships,
family,
children way in the second category,
and so those men are often very
difficult to live with too because
they're so obsessed with their career.
It's hard to have a relationship with
them and maybe they don't have much of a
relationship with their kids,
but they're damn good at what they do
and part of that is they're smart and
disciplined and they'll work nonstop all
the time.
It's like an obsession and that's the
sort of people who run things.
Those are the people who run things
while they're often also disagreeable to
because you want to wrote a manage
people.
Really,
they're not going to like you.
You know when it's not an easy thing to
not be liked,
and actually if you're an agreeable
person and women are more agreeable than
men,
it's quite painful to be disliked,
but if you're in a managerial and
executive position,
the probability that people are going to
like you is quite low.
Now,
if you're a real son of a bitch,
then they're going to dislike you more,
but it's.
It's those.
Those positions are very stressful,
partly because of the interpersonal
dynamics and they're also incredibly,
incredibly competitive,
so the women hit that at and they're
completely qualified in the law.
Firms are bloody desperate to keep them
because it's really hard to find highly
qualified people,
especially once you've put all that time
into training them,
especially if they're also good at
bringing in business.
The law firms trip over themselves to
try to keep them.
They can't.
The women think,
why in the world am I doing this?
Why?
When the world would anyone in their
right mind do this?
Especially because they're often married
by that point too,
and generally they've married a husband
who makes as much money or more than
them so they don't need the damn money,
and so they think,
well,
there's more to life than this,
which is exactly the right thing to
think,
and so they go and find a job that's
nine to five and controllable so that
they can hire a nanny and have some kids
and have a life,
and it's like,
yes,
that's the intelligent thing to do.
So we've got things backwards in our
culture.
We're thinking at least in part,
why aren't there more women in positions
of power?
Wrong question.
The right question is why are there any
minute all who want those positions of
power?
Because it's not just positions of
power.
You have to be such a knothead to think
that,
oh,
it's a position of power.
It's like,
sure,
but it's a position of overwhelming
responsibility and if you make mistakes,
you're done.
Right?
It's not like you occupy that position
of power and everyone does what they're
told all the time in your life is easy.
It's like,
forget about that.
People are on your case to do exactly
the right thing all the time,
100 percent of the time and maybe you
want that.
Maybe you don't.
So the what I don't know what people
think is these people are all sitting in
their offices with their feet up on the
desk,
smoking cigars and pressing the world.
It's like that isn't how it works.
Those people,
they work flat out all the time,
so and it's fine if that's what you want
and some people are like that.
They're hyper industrious people,
right?
From a trade perspective,
no matter where you put them,
if you put them in a forest with an axe,
they just wander around,
chopping down trees nonstop,
right?
Because there it's built into them.
But if you want to have a balanced life
and you should want that,
you know,
because the other thing you'll find,
this is God's Gospel.
Truth is that the older you get,
if you have any sense at all,
the more important your family is to you
like that.
The,
the utility of your career.
Maybe that peaks around 35 or 40 and it
starts to decline pretty rapidly after
that,
and what happens if you're fortunate,
you have someone in your life that you
love,
that you've woven yourself together with
and you have some kids so that you have
something to do from the time you're 50
till the time you're 80,
and so it's a real mistake.
It's a barren future without children,
man,
I can tell you that it's a real mistake
and so we do a terrible job of say,
putting that image forward and saying,
well,
yeah,
now you know,
because women have access to the birth
control pill now and can compete in the
same domains as men.
Roughly speaking,
there is a real practical problem here.
It's partly an economic problem now
because when I was roughly your age,
it was still possible for a one income
family do exist.
While you know that wages have been flat
except in the upper one percent since
1973.
Why?
Well,
it's easy.
What happens when you double the labor
force?
What happens?
You have the value of labor,
so now we're in a situation where it
takes two people to make as much as one
did before.
So we went from a situation where
women's career opportunities were
relatively limited to where they were
relatively unlimited and there were two
incomes to wear and so women could work
to a situation where women have to work
and they only make half as much as they
would have otherwise and now we're going
to go into a situation.
This is the next step.
Whereas women will work because men
won't.
And that's what's coming now.
So we.
There was an economics economist
articles showing that 50 percent now of
of boys in school or having trouble with
their basic subjects and you look around
you and universities,
you can see this happening and I've
watched it over decades.
I would say 90 percent of the people in
my personality class are now women.
There won't be a damn man left and
university in 10 years except in the
stem fields and it's a complete bloody
catastrophe and it's a catastrophe for
women because I don't know where the
hell you're going to find someone to,
to have,
uh,
you know,
to marry and have a family with.
If this keeps happening.
So.
And you think when you're 19 because
you're so clueless when you're 19,
you don't know a bloody thing.
You think,
well,
I'm not really sure I want children
anyway.
So it's like,
oh yeah,
you can tell how well you've been
educated.
Jesus,
dismal,
dismal without fail.
I got to tell you,
without fail,
I've watched women go through their
professional careers.
Many,
many of them.
It's a very rare woman who at the age of
30,
he doesn't consider having a child.
Her primary desire and the ones that
don't consider that.
Generally in my observation,
there's something that isn't quite right
in the way that they're constituted,
are looking at the world.
Sometimes you get women who are truly
non maternal.
You know,
by temperament there.
They have a masculine tempera
disagreeable.
They're not,
they're not particularly compassionate,
they're not maternal,
they don't really.
They're not that interested in kids.
Fair enough,
man,
but there aren't that many of them and
there's plenty who will not admit to
themselves that that's what they most
desperately want.
Do you think women would be better off
or their favorite?
Thirty.
Who knows?
Like it's like it really is a problem
now.
It's a really tough one.
I don't think anybody knows the answer
to that because
35 new kids are saying 10:11.
Then you can go and get a bachelor's and
masters easy that way.
Having the career first and then trying
to raise young kids.
Yeah,
I,
I can't answer that because I've seen
women do a good job of it both both ways
and you do get the odd woman who manages
a high powered career and kids,
but Jesus,
those women,
man,
like they,
they,
they buy more powerful microwaves
because take 45 seconds to cook the food
instead of a minute and I'm not kidding.
It's like they're,
they're up at five.
They exercise for half an hour.
They make breakfast,
they get their kids ready to work,
they go to work,
they worked 14 hours a 14 hour days flat
bloody out.
They come home and work for another two
hours to get their kids organized.
They have a nanny to help them out and
then they work for two more hours before
they go to bed at like one and then
they're up at five and they do that
again and I'll tell you,
you better be tough if you're going to
do that physically too because you'll
just burn yourself to a crisp.
I've seen some women manage it,
you know,
but they're like,
they're tough and they're rare because
that's a hell of a hell of a regimen.
And then if anything goes wrong,
you know,
you have a sick kid or something like
that,
or there's any sort of crisis in your
family.
It's just,
you know,
it's,
then it becomes too much.
And I don't know the answer to that,
you know,
I mean,
the advantage women have is they live
about eight years longer than men
because testosterone kills men.
So Limited.
Well that,
that,
that's right.
They pay up front and gain on the,
on the,
on,
in the long run,
but how it isn't clear how our society
should sort this out.
We don't know.
And it's partly we don't know what to do
now that women have control over their
reproductive function.
It's a big mystery.
Yep.
But I think later on competition and
that's always a conference.
People are always hiring talent because
there's.
Yup.
Yes.
Well,
and the thing is young,
stupid people have the advantage of
being young,
middle aged,
stupid people have the disadvantage of
being middle aged.
And so if you're going to hire a young
stupid person or a middle aged stupid
person,
you'll go for the young,
stupid person.
And I'm stupid.
I mean,
you know,
no,
I'm being sarcastic obviously,
but I mean without,
without experience and just getting
started in the world,
you're much more likely to favor someone
young because there's an instant
explanation for their relative
cluelessness and it's a problem,
you know,
so.
So I don't know what the answer is,
but one,
one answer certainly is,
at least in part,
is to start letting young women know
what being 30 and being female is like
because and also to disabuse them of the
notion that there's something magical
about a career.
First of all,
most people don't have careers,
man,
they have jobs and the reason you get
paid for a job is because you're being
asked to do things you wouldn't do
unless you were being paid.
And so it's not.
It's not some not some utopia of cigar
smoking with your boots up on your desk,
that's for sure.
Not,
not that that would be such a utopia to
begin with.